what is up everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder I'm your host Warren
Thompson and lately there has been a ton
of rumors and reports going around about
the Fantastic Four about Dr Doom and
about the X-Men but today we might have
the craziest report yet as we actually
could have a release date for the first
debut of the first member of the
Fantastic Four if this report ends up
being true we also have some fantastic
forecasting news as well as some general
MCU casting news as well two recent
reports state that two major actors
could be joining the MCU one as the
thing for the Fantastic Four and the
other could be a part of the Fantastic
Four but the role has not been specified
yet so they could be playing any role in
the MCU and of course this all comes
around the same time that we got the
Doom news from the Howard Stern Show and
if you missed that news don't worry I
will briefly explain it in this video
and talk about everything you need to
know about all of these new casting
reports so let's not waste any time
let's dive into it but of course if
you're new to the channel and you love
Marvel and superheroes be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news now let's talk about
the first MCU casting rumor that is just
general for right now and it is Ryan
Gosling Ryan Gosling who is about to
play Ken in the upcoming Barbie movie is
reportedly joining the cast of an
upcoming Marvel project that is set to
film next year now this is coming from
the verified Twitter account called Des
Moines an account that says that they
are curators of pop culture and this is
interesting news but what makes this
even more interesting is that the
website giant freaking robot has
actually reported this before and they
stated that Ryan Gosling is playing Nova
now we know recently that a Nova project
has been announced we didn't really get
any details about this but according to
Giant freaking robot they have cast
their Nova and that is Ryan Gosling and
I'm curious to hear what you all think
about this casting let me know in the
comments down below I personally really
like Ryan Gosling but I'm trying to wrap
my head around him playing Nova as far
as the look goes I definitely think he
has the look I definitely think he has
the body type for it and if this report
is true this means that they are going
for an older Nova specifically Richard
Ryder is the one that is said to be
coming to the MCU and I've seen a lot of
comments online and some people really
would love Ryan Gosling to play Richard
Ryder and it seems like some people
really would not like him to play that
role so let me know what you think in
the comments and as for this next
casting it is for the Fantastic Four and
the actor that is going to be playing
the thing is reportedly Jason Segal now
this is a very very interesting choice
one I just want to state that I do
actually like Jason as an actor How I
Met Your Mother is one of my favorite TV
shows and Forgetting Sarah Marshall is
one of my favorite movies and he's
fantastic in both he's a great actor
however I would have never thought that
he would be cast as the thing now keep
in mind this is not confirmed it's just
a report that was posted to 4chan
however there are some things in this
report that do make it seem kind of
legitimate and I'll explain why here's
all the details that were posted it says
title says it Segal is the thing plays a
major role in the last three episodes of
She-Hulk he was originally meant to
debut in no way home before landing in
She-Hulk Jennifer has a mystery client
who only communicates with her via a
different lawyer and there are a lot of
jokes about this who has a lawyer just
to talk to lawyers it continues to say
the character is being done in a mocap
suit by Jason Segal similar to how they
did Thanos and the thing is fighting a
defamation case it says he shows up in
episode 8 has fight scenes in 9 and 10
and mainly fights The Wrecking Crew it
says there's a moment Where She Hulk the
thing and Daredevil share the screen
there's a moment with Daredevil about
being from New York in their respective
areas it's sort of a more jabby version
of cap and Spider-Man in Civil War now
if this is true this is pretty freaking
crazy She-Hulk is going to be pretty
fantastic if this report is true we're
going to get She-Hulk the thing and
Daredevil now Daredevil and She Hulk is
pretty much confirmed plus he's getting
his own show and is supposed to pop up
in a few other shows beforehand She-Hulk
being one of them the echo series being
another but the thing showing up in
She-Hulk is sort of a surprise
especially if he's going to be played by
Jason Segal but before we dive further
into this here's something that is
pretty interesting about this report
I've seen some people say that this
report is disproven because there's only
Nine episodes of She-Hulk however there
was originally supposed to be 10
episodes of She-Hulk one episode got cut
so if this is true I'm thinking that it
was reported before they cut the 10th
episode and that's the report that we're
seeing and that's why it has 10 episodes
and not just nine now who knows what
they cut from it but since this says
that the thing was supposed to be in
three episodes I'm assuming that the
thing if this report is true is still
going to be in the show and this will be
our first introduction to the Fantastic
Four in the MC now here's kind of the
cool thing one is yes the Fantastic Four
coming to the MCU we know that the movie
is in development we know they're
looking for a new director right now
after John Watts backed out but the
really cool thing is is we can actually
pinpoint when episode 8 which is
supposed to be the debut of the thing
and She-Hulk is going to be you see
She-Hulk debuts on August 17th that is
going to be the first episode so all we
have to do is jump forward seven more
episodes to find out the eighth
episode's date so let's simply jump
forward the 17th is the first episode
the 24th would be the second the 31st
would be the third September 7th would
be the 4th September 14th would be the
5th September 21st the 6th September
28th the 7th and October 5th would be
the eighth episode so if this report
ends up being true you can expect to see
the thing on October 5th in the She-Hulk
series on Disney plus however this
report does say he's supposed to be in
three episodes and it says that one of
the episodes was the 10th episode
however there's only Nine episodes now
and if the thing is still in three
episodes that means he should debut on
the seventh episode which means the
first Fantastic Four debut in the MCU
would be on September 28th now keep in
mind right now this report is just kind
of a rumor right now it's not confirmed
but here's the really cool news we have
some really big things coming up really
soon Marvel Studios is attending San
Diego Comic-Con and this is typically
where they announce all of their really
big projects in the past over the last
handful of years Marvel Studios released
phase four here and they dropped all of
their big name projects at Hall h at San
Diego Comic-Con so they're attending
this year so we should expect some
pretty big news also d23 is coming up
and apparently Marvel Studios has some
pretty big announcements for us there as
well not to mention Disney plus day
we'll talk about all the upcoming Marvel
Disney plus projects and on top of that
Kevin feige recently came out in an
interview and stated that we're kind of
going to get hints at what the future
holds very very soon and we're going to
start to see how things kind of are
going to come together so hopefully we
hear some news about the Fantastic Four
after all at San Diego Comic-Con in 2019
the last time that Marvel Studios was
there in person Kevin feige did tease
the Fantastic Four so it's been years
now so hopefully we're gonna hear some
type of news also not to mention Howard
Stern did talk about a doom project
recently he did not specifically say
that he is playing Doctor Doom he simply
said he is doing Dr Doom this could
refer to a movie this could refer to a
TV show but a lot of signs have told us
that the Fantastic Four are in
development right now and maybe the cast
has already all been chosen and if so
all of that combined with some rumors
from insiders stating that Doctor Doom
is coming soon I'm assuming that Doctor
Doom is getting his own project and of
course this is going to come hand in
hand with the Fantastic Four so big big
things happening in the MCU right now if
you're not excited about phase four and
phase five yet you should get excited
because it sounds like things are about
to get pretty dang crazy so if you love
Marvel and want to stay up to date on
all the news happening be sure to
subscribe and hit that Bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf